I should say my proposal was for a
balanced budget increase and I think
that it wouldn't have increased the
national debt I agree that it's a source
of problem but I don't know that it
solves everything
there are problems increasing interest
rupture investment I think we've been a
little bit glib about that and if you
look at the CBO report about this failed
American Jobs Act they don't have any
optimism that the infrastructure
investment would be very big in the
short run it's hard to ramp these things
up and so it's not going to solve the
9.1% unemployment problem but it's a
step in that direction and I think that
maybe I agree with you the real thing is
to think about long-term growth and that
means developing our financial
institutions and making make moving
forward on a number of different I can
just briefly say something about
infrastructure so while I sympathize
actually quite a lot with the need to
improve the infrastructure in this
country we'll all know the difference
between you know the train system in the
US and but I mean you really know the
impact of infrastructure and growth I
guess the only serious piece of work on
this I know is from Raj in India from
the late 19th century there's certainly
a lot of uncertainty about the impact of
the increase in infrastructure and the
second thing is actually emphasizes that
unfortunately the decisions on
infrastructure which needs to be built
is done by the government and I will
build an infrastructure for yesterday's
economy are the trains that are old so I
will build an infrastructure for
tomorrow's economy you know who knows
what's going to be there in 10 years
maybe we need to build the spectrum and
the the new telecommunication thing and
between the uncertainty about the impact
on of the estimates of the impact of
infrastructure long term growth and the
general I think inability of the
government to pick winners
I don't think that infrastructure is a
silver bullet that's gonna help the
economy in general I think there is no
silver bullet and I think I agree with
Bob one on two things I agree that
improving financial markets is essential
and important and one has to remember
that not over-regulate now the tendency
of the regulatory pendulum to me seems
to go away on the side of
over-regulation and there are long term
problems I think are essential to
address a little bit the issue of long
run versus short run and I think allies
points I think are worth really
emphasizing that I'd put them in a
slightly different way it's that when we
think of designing programs to alleviate
there are short long difficulties and to
get back to full employment we need to
make sure that we have ones that don't
stunt long-term growth and I think that
so I think in a way Europe is a good is
is a good object lesson to keep in mind
that we don't do things that are the
worst of Europe for example a
work-sharing kinds of arrangements are
the kinds of programs so we might say
we'll have a mandatory reduction in
hours worked because they're only
there's a kind of lump of Labor and
let's shared out among the existing
workers that's been a program in Europe
I think it probably has been a failed
one there so that those I think we have
to be very careful in introducing our
short-run programs that we don't do
those kinds of programs that will stunt
long-term growth at the same time I want
I want to I would like to emphasize that
some of the things that are happening in
the short run are very damaging to the
long run investment is low so we're
going to end up at the end of this cycle
with a lower capital stock than we would
have we'll end up with less investment
in research and development and probably
worst of all is that the atrophying of
job skills from people who've been out
of the labor market
long periods of time who've not been
able to upgrade their skills and had the
experience on-the-job experience so I
think we we have the prospect of having
I would say a generation but a whole
group of workers who've who basically
haven't gone through the period of
developing the job skills so at the end
of this I think our human and capital is
going to be substantially less than it
would be and I think one of the reasons
to get back to full employment is to
actually have more capital and better
skilled and more experienced workers so
part of it ought to be to get back in a
way that doesn't that gets us back to
the more capital and and more
experienced workers without shortcoming
that the government first of all
infrastructure we're talking about
public goods so it has to be a public
decision the American Jobs Act which was
just blocked in Congress would have
created a corporation called the
American infrastructure financing
Authority that would consult with
private sector people about making plans
for infrastructure martin shubik
proposal is for what he calls a federal
employment reserve authority it sounds
like the áifá that was but it has a
clear focus on the long term what shubik
wants is to have a government agency
that is continually in place to think
about long term projects that will be
available and suitable for
implementation should there be a
downturn it's interesting that I should
be didn't know this when he proposed it
but actually under the Roosevelt
administration they briefly tried
something called the Public Works
reserve which was a research group that
was supposed to plan exactly almost
exactly what she'll be proposed but it
didn't work effectively because it was
created in uncertain times in World War
two
but I think that's the kind of thing
that we we have to get going we have to
start thinking about
infrastructure in the long run and get
into a position and it doesn't have to
be the government so I had the
opportunity to serve on the NSF panel
once for economics and I saw how the
government can work the national sound
of a National Science Foundation is a
wonderful example of how the government
can bring in outside thinkers and we had
a panel of experts that in fact Tom
Sargent the new Nobel Prize winner was
on our panel when I was on we had good
people I think the government can do a
good job in if it's not the government
it's the people of this country that are
doing the job let me just add something
about the timing of job creation I I
think the Trueba Kai dia is a good one
if having a plan that you could speed up
in if there were a downturn I think that
makes a lot of sense you might even go a
little further in thinking about this
this is a fairly radical idea but but
it's it's worth thinking about the
Federal Reserve is independent of
Congress it basically can make actions
to change monetary policy through its
own governance processes 95 percent at a
time that's adequate for managing the
economy you don't have to have big
swings in fiscal policy only monetary
policy and that sufficient tool to sort
of you know prevent overheating of the
economy frankly had it been interest
rates been taken up or collateral rates
taken up by the Federal Reserve in in
the in the four or five years prior to
the collapse we would not be on the we
would not have the problem we have now
so monetary policy typically works in a
deep recession though we as a couple of
panels were saying I think monetary
policy doesn't work interest rates are
zero further cuts to the interest rate
unless you could create inflationary
expectations will are not are not
possible and are not going to and
they're not going to actually shift the
mix and stimulate spending and get the
economy restarted so so the question is
how do we you know you have to use
fiscal policies
logic and miracle evidence and it's very
hard for the Congress to mobilize on a
short-term basis as we've seen and we
did not get very effective action out of
Congress the early package was something
politically palpable payroll tax cut
which had very little impact because
people were over leveraged and so they
paid down their credit card debt with
the extra the extra percentage point or
two that they got in their paycheck they
didn't spend so so what's the solution
well maybe some kind of standby
commission that can make a certain
limited range of fiscal policy decisions
when some trigger is hit such as
unemployment rate spikes by three
percentage points or something like that
it would be it's a it's a constant above
maybe not constitutional it could be
done by legislation but it's an idea of
worth thinking about for the to get us
out of the next possible happened which
I think should also be made permanent is
the Fed realized that banks weren't
lending and all kinds of markets were
collapsing like the credit card market
the student loan market those were all
on the verge of disappearing entirely
and so the Fed went around the banks and
went on the securitizations so they they
realized that when you're in a crisis
and people are asking for it's not that
the private sector wanted too high an
interest rate they wanted too much
collateral and so the Fed went around
them and Lane and loaned with less
collateral the private sector was
demanding so I think that we should have
a permanent facility to step in in case
there's a disaster like that again it's
analogous to the idea of a standby
facility to get ready to you know do
some infrastructure projects if all of a
sudden you have a lot of
people I want to say one more thing
about the Fed the Fed so the Fed has
done a quite good job you know the
crisis could have been much worse but
it's not it's not that adventurous the
Fed for all the talk I mean it missed
the crisis the same guys running the Fed
now just had no clue what was going on
before the crisis and then they couldn't
be much more radical you know they we
haven't reached the end of the line
we're determined not to have any
inflation because that you know somehow
we can't if inflation must be a disaster
crazy or something but if we set a price
target that you know in the next few
years we're going to try and see prices
rise by 20 percent so we don't want a
permanent inflation what prices to go up
in the near term for a while that's a
kind of policy they've never even
considered in fact you can hardly raise
it at the Fed if you go to Jackson mall
or something it's barely mention it they
think you're crazy but one of the ways
of getting out of a hugely indebted
economy one of the standard ways of
getting out of it is inflating away the
debt and you always have to worry that
if you start an inflation will spiral
out of control I think the most likely
way we're gonna get an inflation that
spirals out of control as if the Fed
repeats over and over again that there
can't be an inflation they have enough
tools to prevent it they're never gonna
give up let it go above two percent and
then it does go above two percent anyway
then people worry that it's out of
control so I so I think that would be
I'm not sure this idea actually is that
good but it's a radical idea that we
considered seriously so the fact is we
have to do different things we have to
manage leverage that's not something the
Fed is willing to do the ECB in Germany
I mean in Frankfurt yes but the head of
the whole European Central Bank Trichet
I said what about managing leverage and
he said well it's very important but
we'll manage the interest rate and maybe
somebody else could manage leverage and
I said you know that's like the old
Russia the old Russia where they had one
Bureau in charge of prices another
Bureau in charge of quantities so you
know you want to have the whole thing in
one place so I believe that this crisis
is being a stimulus to a more radical
rethink of a lot of our policy tools in
the long run may be very helpful to the
thing that I might disagree with here is
our discussion seem so divorced from the
current political discussion right we're
in a political environment where the Fed
is not being criticized for doing too
little the Fed is being criticized for
doing too much the the you know so the
idea that we're going to create another
Fed like institution with independence
you know seems completely you know why I
don't know because you know six people
here you know almost great thing we've
said is politically feasible today
absolutely nothing we've said it's a
politically feasible that's my point
yeah should have done more to rescue the
unemployed and to rescue the 99 percent
that you talked about and I agree that
we should get more you know I mean
really take your bless more seriously I
mean what is the point of having an
economics department at a great
university except to think about what
would be the right things to do it's not
our job to make the politics happen I
mean that's that it's unfortunate that
the that the politics are extremely hard
here extremely hard but but you know
some people should be saying you know
what according to you know the
accumulated body of evidence and they
and it within economics would make sense
and that's what I think that's the
spirit of this conversation so I agree
with that I mean I think I'm just saying
you know I think it's worth thinking
about the next step which is you know if
this isn't part of if these kind of
solutions are completely infeasible why
are they infeasible why is this not part
you know of a national conversation on
these issues and you know maybe Occupy
Wall Street is you know a step towards
that good could I say that the fiscal
stimulus is not infeasible you have one
you have a president whose proposed it
you have a majority at one house that is
in favor of a variant of it and you've
got another house that's just putting up
resistance so okay as compared to some
of the other ideas that we've had it's
actually it's both it's both in the
mainstream of what macro Caliph's think
is a good idea and it's not completely
infeasible so I think we shouldn't write
it off nobody we still got it
but we do have in deference to the
politic political environment we still
we do have a fiscal stimulus that like
the first one is two-thirds tax cuts and
one-third job creation and is not enough
well okay so there are there are
differences of opinion on taxes versus
expenditures and it and so I don't think
everybody thinks that you can only have
expenditure and infrastructure increases
that there is actually a good body of
opinion that says tax cuts are effective
they don't have the same bang for a buck
as expenditures but they are effective I
think what we really run into difficulty
was this long-run fiscal outlook and and
the confusion that I think unfortunate
the president was partly responsible for
until until Labor Day where he basically
bought into the deficit reduction
movement and only after Labor Day did he
kind of change his mind and decided that
really jobs and expansion were more
important than short-run deficit
reduction so I think people are very
confused about that now because for most
of this year until Labor Day the
president basically bought into the
rhetoric of the that deficit expansion
is more important than anything or
deficit reduction is more important than
anything else and it's only recently
that we've
even any argument with that at the very
highest levels